What makes you itch?
What sort of a situation would you like?
That's suppose I do this often in
vocational guidance of students.
They come to me and say,
well,
we're getting out of college and we
haven't the faintest idea what we want
to do.
So I always ask the question,
what would you like to do if money were
no object,
how would you really enjoy spending your
life?
Wow.
It's so amazing.
As a result of our kind of educational
system,
crowds of students say,
well,
we'd like to be painters.
We'd like to be poets,
we'd like to be writers.
But as everybody knows,
you counted on any money that way or not
passage.
This is what I'd like to live an
outdoors life and ride a horses.
I said he wanted to teach in the riding
school.
Uh,
let's go through with it.
What do you want to do?
When we finally got down to something
which the individual says he really
wants to do,
I will say to him,
you do that and uh,
forget the money.
Uh,
because if you say that getting the
money is the most important,
you will spend your life completely
wasting your time.
You'll be doing things you don't like
doing in order to go on living.
That is to go on doing things you don't
like doing,
which is stupid.
Better to have a short life that is full
of what you like doing.
Then a long life in a miserable way.
And after all,
if you do really like what you're doing,
it doesn't matter what what it is,
you can't,
eventually they turn it.
You could eventually become a master of
it is the only way to become a master of
something that we really with it.
And then you'll be able to get a good
fee for whatever it is.
So don't,
don't worry too much that that's the,
everybody's somebody is interested in
everything and anything you can be
interested in,
you will find out as well.
But it's absolutely stupid to spend your
time doing things you don't like in
order to go on spending things you don't
like doing things you got like,
and to teach her children following the
same track.
What we're doing is we're bringing up
children in educating to live the same
sort of lives we are living in order
that they may justify themselves and
find satisfaction in life by bringing up
their children to bring up their
children to do the same thing.
So it all rich and no vomit.
It never gets there.
And so therefore it's so important
instead of this question,
what do I desire?
Well,
when my answer that question in a naive
way,
we figured out the vaunted desire.
Uh,
what we want is to control everything
to create girls that don't grow old
apples that don't rot,
close,
that never wear out conveyances that get
from one place to another instance list.
So we don't have to wait power available
to do anything that you could conceive
and do it just instantly like that to
get this funny technological
omnipotence.
But if you take time out to think about
that and really go into it with your
full strength of imagination and find
out whether that's where you want it,
b,
you will soon see that's not what you
want because the moment you have a
situation where you are really in
control of things,
that is to say in which the future is
almost completely predictable.
You will see us.
As I said last night,
that aid completely predictable.
Future is already in the past you've had
it.
That's not what you want.
You want a surprise.
You don't know what that's going to be
because obviously it wouldn't be a
surprise in the food here.
What a pleasant surprise.
I'd like you to say what sort of a
surprise would be pleasant and you can't
really answer that because you know if
there were to be such things as pleasant
surprises,
that must also be unpleasant.
Surprises must be rude shops.
So you are like somebody's taking a one
of those wishing well boxes,
tubs,
you know where you're fishing and you
bring out a package and you don't know
whether you've got a dead rat in it or a
new camera.
That's the way that's,
that seems to be the thing that really
excites people.
But quite set.
And there that comes out of this
inquiry,
a feeling of
real disillusionment with the ideal of
power.
Yeah.
To be in power,
to be in control is not something that
any sense suitable person wants.
You imagine the situation of big brother
Mr j Edgar Hoover,
Heinrich Himmler to be glued day at
night to a highly descended office,
telephone,
television screens,
watching peaky spine,
everyone in anything.
Getting all this information together.
Why you could never leave the office.
I mean that people characterize cause
like they had go hoover's goes home in
the evening and uh,
but when he's back home,
you know,
there are gods sitting outside the door.
Does that hotline telephones going to
something?
He's always having to be in control.
And so when you think things through
like that,
you understand that do not want,
don't want to control it.
And therefore these Zen Buddhist masters
that I met and others were not super
oncologists and very many westerners who
visited Japan expecting to get a Satori
as a result of which they would know
everything and control everything,
but grievously disappointed and said,
there's not much in the south.